on va avancer et faire le focus de l'été
sur hp il a été on va pas se mentir
l'événement en audience de cette saison
il ya longtemps que tf1 ait pas fait des
scores pareil première l'épisode 9
millions 250 mille téléspectateurs après
7 millions 8,7 millions 9,6 millions 8
bref c'est un vrai talent carton ou vous
a fait un petit récap et ensuite on va
donner des notes qui je veux et je te
l'espère seront bonnes
pour cette deuxième saison d'âge pays
tf1 a mis le paquet notamment sur le
budget sucette
[Musique]
et aussi avec des courses poursuite
digne des plus grands films
hollywoodiens
[Musique]
tout ça pour pas grand chose au final
vous feriez pas la soeur de fébriles
moutier une saison haute en couleur donc
à la pointe de la mode avec de grosses
séquences passionne
et une session shopping com ont pour en
connaître au moins tous les jours
finalement ya quelqu'un
la wii est quelqu'un
hockey et au mit hpi c'est avant tout
des meurtres et des enquêtes aussi
compliquée à résoudre au plus et dom la
lame par exemple aller très fine de type
e petit couteau ou le capteur posez-la
négligemment 1 par exemple
bizarre et heureusement pour mettre un
peu de bonne humeur parmi tous ces
crimes on peut toujours compter sur
audrey fleurot
là je faisais trop serré vous voulez que
je déplace pas voiture
[Musique]
alors certes
ça fait des relances en public en
ménagère saqqara qu alors des niveaux
tous les frappeurs des chiffres bien sûr
9 millions 1000 5000 téléspectateurs en
moyenne sur la saison s'étend aux sur
toutes les cibles 43 % de part
d'audience et sur les fameux sommes
responsables des achats ces 54 % vous
aimez bien c'est le carton d'un point de
vue économique aussi pour tf1 bien sûr
quel est votre prochain maxime gagné
1,10 à
succès à faire défection française de 17
ans non pourquoi parce que j'ai une
capitaine marc loos il s était fait
alors vous avez lu segueni non pourquoi
s'il vous plaît quand même sur place ils
ont poussé les curseurs de la comédie en
tout cas sur cette saison 2 avec
beaucoup de drama et contrairement à ce
qu'on peut penser c'est que les enquêtes
sont extrêmement bien mené avec des
twists de faim et pourquoi ça cartonne
autant dans le monde 105 pays l'ont
acheté ces 105 p à 105,6 et français à
l'international même succès français et
pas vraiment aidé à tresses l'italie et
l'espagne ont rejeté la série avant même
la diffusion la saison une ce qui est
extrêmement rare en matière de fiction
française qui l'attend générale or les
deuxièmes sage donc au bout d'une bêtise
qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle des screenings
chaque année en fait on diffuse des
petits bouts d'experts et des chaînes
près achète et c'est d'ailleurs l'un il
ya mille ailleurs une course entre les
différents thèmes ce qui commence à
diffuser une minute deux minutes et dix
ans sortent de la salle pour aller en hd
vécu des mois la moue de bagout vers ce
qu'ils étaient fin a été très fort là
dessus parce que capitaine marleau sur
france 3 avec un carton énorme dans le
même état d'esprit qui a peut-être
marleau
il y avait de l'humour avec de très
bonnes enquêtes et france 3 a cartonné
et tf1 a très bien rebondi parce que
non j'ai pas fait marcher dessus vous
préserve ses malades j'aime beaucoup
captain harlock au match pays de galles
dossier âgées mme paula là tu cries
forte aux ménages voudrait ça je n'ai
pas du tout cas de mario je vous le dis
je vous jure
il aime pas le cas avec un bonnet
péruvien acquis c'est bête de l'enquète
ça m'énerve balle à l'entrée d'un truc
de regarder un peu inférieur
alors que tu la trouves tu es jolie que
l'on alors pas du tout ça va rester
comme je te connais c'est pas utile mais
question de jeu voilà c'est une question
d'acting sur l'exacte e mans voilà merci
beaucoup de monde à 17 combien vous
mettez trois oui alors moi je mets trois
alors je suis désolé je vais peut-être
être la seule qui n'aime pas moi j'ai
vraiment du mal avec cette série
pourquoi parce que déjà au niveau du
scénario je me tue d'astrakan crédible
donc non ça me paraît pas crédible de
deux j'en ai marre des séries policières
sur tf1 pourquoi est-ce qu'à chaque fois
on fait des séries policières mais en
quoi on a cette obsession monomaniaque
en france de ne faire que des séries
policières
non non c'est toujours les briques à
l'eau dans des restaurants alors non en
france ont fait que des séries
policières de deux heures c'est de
remporter un jeu explique gagner mais
c'est pas pour ça que ça me plaît j'en
ai marre j'aimerais qu'on parle de 2 6%
c'est pas une série musée ne pas laisser
les policiers reprennent comme par
exemple oui on sait si les prix de l'or
en plus je trouve que la saison 2 est
nettement moins bien dans les allées
vers l'ailleurs revenir alors je vous
dis à ton père l'air par principe j'aime
beaucoup de reyff l'euro donc stop
arrêtez vous
j'ai la chance d'être patron ce soir
donc vous ne dirai plus
elle est canon est tous bien arrêtées
les images de la
[Applaudissements]
doré à l'or jambiers 0 top
simplement parce que il ya dix ans
j'aurais peut-être me dise
malheureusement maintenant la plus
mauvaise série sur netflix est meilleur
que c'est normal mais sans toi tu vas
jamais sexy sur une autre plate fois tcl
sont netflix une plateforme il ya des
séries du monde dressé avec des séries
israélienne espagnol intrigues de tous
les pays argentine ça qu'ils sont
excellents avec des scénarios bien plus
riches et à des us pour une série a bel
et bien alors je dis bien les critiques
et bien il ya bien mais ni de bouquets
forme il ya joué c'est bien joué c'est
osé franchement on passe de temps à
taper sur tout le monde dans cette
émission n'ont pas volé son au moins
pour une fois qu'il ya un truc qui
marche qu'ils aillent en plus ben non
c'est parce que parfois ça marche et ou
on n'aime pas mais là ça marche et de la
londe m bah oui c'est pas parce que ça
marche que j'aimais et hébétée 0 et
métiers 0 voilà magané deux
déjà son potentiel intellectuel
ma peau est déjà au potentiel
intellectuel
mais en fait elle à la cuite 152 à
la leur au sommeil cruche à la cruche
mais c'est pas une crue
écouter ça
c'est un compliment que je vous fais oui
elle a l'air d'une crue manu
mais ce n'est pas un tricheur
j'ai encore les deux premières à écouter
si vous retenez ce que vous voulez le
débat c'est si je suis cru tout pâle
alors non on est moche non merci c'est
gentil h près du coup je me dis aux gens
me disent
c'est bon justin nom vous est venue ou
pas non après je regarde pas parce que
c'est en fait j'aime pas les séries
françaises où il essaie de sajoo
américaine cancer trop choqué l'amérique
c'est un show américain voici ma maison
ma générique vous êtes s'est dit c'est
digne d'une série américaine
en fait ça que ça joue à mai à
l'américaine a écouté que vous trouve
très bon programme en france et n'a pas
besoin
de ça
français se soient engrenage qui s'est
vendue dans plus de 150
% par exemple ça se collent pas aux
etats unis c'est france fonctionne dès 5
heures à beyrouth où et n'importe quoi à
l'eau dans la production dans la dans la
dans le jeu des comédiens dans tout ça
on c'est vrai que ça vaut pas section de
recherches a à ça c'était les
teletubbies ses banlieues ou 300
policiers nous dire c'est de la merde
savoir annaba alors si tu avais une
enquête policière en était d'étudier un
moment alors que les voyelles la moyenne
des nez rouges c'est bien et hi5 24
c'est
franchement 54 et bah franchement ça me
fait de la peine
à vous avez des parts sachez que depuis
longtemps gelé départ nulle part vous
devez savoir
ce départ de dette elle est parlée par